bonsoir
alors je vais poser une question pour
commencer est-ce que il y en a qui ont
comme moi aujourd'hui des chaussures V
déjà soit là dans la salle soit chez eux
soit ils ont des copains qui ont des
chaussures VGA est-ce que vous pouvez la
main ceux qui sont dans ce cas là c'est
un petit sondage
alors voilà il y en a un petit peu
pas tant que ça merci redescendre le
bras alors ceux qui connaissent pas les
chaussures wedja c'est une marque qui
est réputée pour être très
éco-responsable il y a beaucoup de
matériaux recyclés dans la chaussure le
coton est 100% bio
ils ont remplacé le cuir par une matière
vegan biosourcée
ça doit être bien travaillé chez vedia
ça c'est un boulot qui a du sens
on fait des choses sur écolo
et puis le secteur de la chaussure pas
tellement polluant
quoi que
quoi que si on réfléchit bien bon faut
quand même la fabriquer cette chaussure
donc il y en a dit qu'il y avait des
matériaux faut déjà extraire tous les
matériaux faut aussi fabriquer les
chaussures ça émet du CO2 déjà tout ça
bon
et puis il faut pas oublier les autres
limites planétaires extraction des
ressources donc il y a les ressources
qu'on comprend impact sur la
biodiversité et production de déchets à
chaque fois qu'on va aller jeter
est-ce que vous savez en France combien
on achète chaque année de paire de
chaussures
il y en a qui disent beaucoup c'est pas
faux chaque année
on achète plus de 400 millions de paires
de chaussures des pères
ça fait beaucoup caleçons millions ça
fait plus de 5 paires par personne
c'est quand même pas mal
bon alors les déchets on parlait tout à
l'heure ça fait combien de déchets dans
tout ça et bien les déchets
on en a plus de 300 millions de paires
de chaussures jetées à la poubelle
chaque année
tu as fait beaucoup beaucoup tout ça
beaucoup de déchets bon mais vous me
direz maintenant tous ces sujets là on
connaît on maîtrise alors il doit y
avoir forcément un plan quelque part
pour diminuer le nombre de déchets sur
le secteur de la chaussure
alors pas tant que ça il s'est un petit
peu le problème
les déchets des chaussures voilà on peut
difficilement recycler il y a plus de en
moyenne 13 matériaux différents dans la
chaussure ça peut monter jusqu'à 40
matériaux différents pour des chaussures
de sport donc recycler ça c'est pas
facile il faut tous séparer bref c'est
un casse-tête et on le fait très très
peu ce qui fait que le sujet maltraité
et le secteur de la chaussure lui ce
qu'il veut surtout c'est développer la
Fédération des détaillants en chaussures
de France leurs deux gros sujets
aujourd'hui c'est le développement c'est
l'aménagement de la période des soldes
et la concurrence avec les boutiques en
ligne
le secteur de la chaussure s'il pouvait
arriver avant de 500 millions de paires
de chaussures par an il serait très
content c'est la logique du modèle en
place toujours plus
ce qu'on veut dire par là c'est que
concevoir une chaussure et
correspondable écolo c'est forcément
très bien mais ça en fait pas pour
autant un secteur qui est soutenable si
le secteur il veut toujours faire plus
développer plus vendre plus vendre plus
produire plus vendre plus c'est un
modèle de travail qu'on appelle le
productivisme et ce modèle là ça marche
pas bien avec le fait d'essayer de
sortir de la société de consommation
acheter moins les notions de sobriété
dont on parle tous maintenant et c'est
vrai sur les autres secteurs également
qui n'a pas en tant que salarié dans sa
boîte comme objectif la croissance la
compétitivité l'innovation
un entrepreneur un indépendant forcément
il veut développer sa boîte c'est normal
le message premier
est de dire que le travail tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui doit s'adapter
fortement car le productivisme est
incompatible des limites planétaires et
de la notion de justice sociale dont on
va parler tout à l'heure pour faire
simple on pourrait dire que
décarboner un secteur c'est très très
loin d'être suffisant
quel travailleur dans tout ça
nous les humains des pays d'y développés
somme de plus en plus nombreux à être
conscient des envieux des enjeux
socio-écologiques
et
que peuvent nous faire comment
pouvons-nous mener ces adaptations que
nous allons devoir mettre en œuvre
nous sommes au prémices d'une démarche
collective de sobriété qui au travers de
nos actes de travail nous mènent selon
Arthur Keller vers en tant que rouage
d'un système qui est extractiviste
productiviste
consumériste croissantiste et
pollutionniste c'est pareil et tout ça
et qui du coup a servi le vivant dont
nous faisons partie faut pas oublier de
le rappeler et tous nos actes de travail
y participent
que ce soit
la personne qui participe à extraire le
pétrole le pilote de ligne le banquier
ou encore le professeur l'infirmière
le fabricant de chaussures toujours plus
de chaussures comme nous expliquer Bruno
le détaillant de cuir toujours plus de
cuir
mais aussi le juriste
le cuisinier la secrétaire qui participe
à leur niveau à faire fonctionner la
société
nous
sommes au final face à de plus en plus
de déshumanisation
qui dans le cadre du travail dit moderne
et industrialisé nous amène à des pertes
de sens et à des dissonances cognitives
qui sont croissantes
je parle de déshumanisation parce
qu'aujourd'hui
le travailleur c'est un élément
interchangeable d'un système scientiste
mesuré pour contrôler
et techniciste
mais il est aussi vu comme une ressource
au même titre que la biosphère dans un
système qui au final est complètement
on va dire
dans le monde de rationalité économique
ça c'est perdre de sens grandissante
la question qu'on se pose et qui est en
lien avec la manière dont le travail est
découpé en sous tâche où tout le monde
est devenu spécialiste
c'est comment faisons-nous pour garder
au final une vision
de la finalité de l'objet pour lequel on
participe et la fidélité même de
l'activité de notre entreprise ou de
notre environnement de travail
nous pensons que le travail au final
n'est plus là pour servir le bien commun
mais qu'il nous a servi
à des besoins croissants de contrôle et
d'enrichissement d'une petite minorité
aux ateliers car l'association dont nous
faisons partie tous les trois nous
sommes convaincus que la dimension du
travail et non d'emploi on insiste bien
sur cette différence
pour vivre dans des sociétés
respectueuses des ressources et de la de
la biosphère des écosystèmes
doit se faire à travers des
organisations et des discussions
démocratiques un bon exemple pressant et
était la convention citoyenne pour le
climat
mais aussi dans un partage peut-être un
peu plus juste du travail entre les
activités mentales et les activités
manuelles
tout ça dans un objectif de justice
sociale
pourquoi
Apollon nous travail l'activité de la
nounou qui garde nos enfants et pas le
fait de pouvoir choisir de d'éduquer
nous-même nos enfants
il en va de même au final pour la
production et la transformation de
nourriture
mais encore pour la construction de nos
maisons nos habits
ou de la même manière pour tout ce qui
concerne la réparation des différents
objets du quotidien au vélo nos voitures
les différents objets électroniques
qu'on peut utiliser
pour nous le travail doit faire face est
nécessaire adaptation pour se
transformer et ne peut devenir que
marchand comme il l'est aujourd'hui
et il doit aussi être plus justement
partagé pour répondre au Borel besoin de
sociétaux et des territoires donc le
deuxième message qu'on souhaiterait vous
faire passer c'est que le travail doit
être repolitisé du grec politique qui
participent à l'organisme à
l'organisation de la cité
afin de au final pouvoir répondre au
réel besoin sociétaux et à la mise en
place d'action individuelle et
collective
alors que fait-on
que fait-on face à ce qui vient de vous
être dit comment fait-on pour concilier
travail et enjeux écologique et sociaux
et bien au sein des ateliers car notre
association nous pensons qu'en tant que
travailleur nous pouvons et nous devons
agir
à titre individuel Fred a changé de voix
Bruno et moi on est tous les deux passés
à 80%
. ce 80%, ça nous a permis de retrouver
du temps de reprendre possession de
notre temps car souvent pour agir c'est
le temps qui nous manque et ne pas
constamment avoir l'impression d'être
SOUS L'EAU sous la vague
je vais maintenant vous parler d'une
expérimentation concrète et collective
que nous allons mener au sein des
ateliers Icare il s'agit d'une
expérimentation de la polyactivité
plus activité tout simplement ça veut
dire avoir plusieurs activités
professionnelles donc en général une
activité principale et une activité plus
secondaire
au sein des ateliers car on pense que la
politique ça peut être un moyen de
partager de rééquilibrer le travail
notamment entre un travail qui est
purement mental un peu de bureau
intellectuel et un travail qui est pu
être physiquement pénible qui est
souvent peu valorisée socialement et qui
pourtant répond à des besoins vitaux
essentiels
nous pensons tout particulièrement au
secteur de l'agriculture surtout dans
une région telle que la nôtre
l'Occitanie
d'autant que des associations telles que
l'atelier paysan ou encore le chiffre
project ont montré ne serait-ce que pour
respecter la corde de Paris qu'il
faudrait un retour vers ce secteur de
l'agriculture beaucoup plus de main
d'oeuvre dans le secteur de
l'agriculture si nous voulions
développer une agriculture paysanne et
agroécologique
et bien nous pensons que la polyactivité
ça peut être un moyen d'organiser ce
changement de voix plutôt que de faire
le grand saut ou alors simplement de
partager le travail
et en plus on est nombreux à aspirer
avoir des activités plus manuelles
nous sommes donc vous allez chercher des
maraîchers
pour leur exposer notre idée venir un
jour par semaine à tour de rôle pendant
un mois sur leur exploitation pour les
aider et soutenir leur activité et se
former
nous avons rencontré Quentin le
maraîcher et Maryline dessert de Larosa
qui ont tout de suite compris notre
vision marine notamment souhaite créer
davantage de liens entre le monde
citadin un peu hors sol et le monde de
la campagne
ainsi notre expérimentation notre
expérimentation de la polyactivité va
débuter très prochainement le mois
prochain et nous allons venir à tour de
rôle collectivement sur leur terrain
pour nous cette expérimentation n'est
qu'un premier pas pouvoir s'il est
possible de pérenniser une telle
organisation organisation du travail et
voir quelle question cela soulève est-ce
qu'un jour par semaine ça va être
suffisant est-ce qu'il va être facile de
l'onglet de notre activité principale à
cette activité secondaire
est-ce que dans le cas de l'agriculture
c'est plutôt un besoin ponctuel ou
saisonnier qui va être nécessaire
à tonton une rémunération de cette
seconde activité ou au contraire doit-on
sortir du cadre du travail marchandisé
quel autre secteur la polyactivité peut
adresser
et enfin comment fait-on pour que la
polyactivité devienne banale
et vous quatre jours au bureau un jour à
la ferme voire un mi-temps à la ferme ça
vous dit
[Applaudissements]
donc conclue vient de nous l'expliquer
au final la politique semble être une
piste intéressante mais nous sommes
persuadés qu'il en existe encore
beaucoup d'autres pour réussir à
recolitiser le travail
au niveau individuel on peut passer à
temps partiel déjà retrouver du temps ou
s'investir dans une asso mais aussi
bifurquer ou déserté c'est un petit peu
à la mode actuellement pour participer à
des jobs de sens où ont développé de
nouveau
au final pour que la dimension qui est
une redimension politique à nos actes de
à travers le travail nous pensons qu'il
faut absolument que cette modification
cette évolution soit meunier de manière
collective
donc déjà ça pourrait être
identifié tous ensemble de qu'est-ce
qu'on a besoin sociétalement donc au
niveau global au niveau local
mais ça peut être aussi développer des
nouvelles formes de technologie comme
les Lot-et
il faut également réorganiser le travail
collectivement ça veut dire repenser à
des reconversions massives si on a
besoin si on a besoin pensez à des
programmes de formation également à des
mesures ambitieuses de diversification
des entreprises
ou encore réfléchir et réorganiser la
gouvernance et les modèles de
gouvernance des entreprises dans lequel
nous évoluons
au final nous pensons que en synthèse il
nous suffit entre guillemets d'imaginer
de structurer de nouveaux modèles de
développement et bien sûr pas que
économique comme celui dans lequel nous
évoluons
donc en conclusion il nous semble que
c'est on adaptant le travail et son
organisation en repolitisant bien sûr le
travail et en retrouvant une juste place
dans la toile du vivant que nous
retrouvons du sens des pieds dans la
terre et sur terre merci à toutes et à
tous
[Applaudissements]